Emmanuel Macron n'avait pas les
instruments de son ambition il n'avait
pas de partie et on a vu que ça lui
manquait n'avais pas le groupe
parlementaire qu'il avait fait rêver qui
allait nous faire passer dans une
nouvelle ère de la politique et n'avait
pas de l'Etat l'État français que les
Français ont l'habitude de me
considérait comme leur sur moi naturel
en gueulant sans arrêt contre lui mais
en comptant fermement
dans l'action il est il n'était pas au
rendez-vous et c'est ce que le covit la
montre et finalement moins lui que
l'appareil est la politique de ses
prédécesseurs qui fait que ça ne lui ai
pas reprocher mais on a vu l'ampleur des
dégâts tonton ce qu'on peut lui
reprocher c'est de n'avoir pas pris la
mesure au préalable parce qu'il en avait
besoin pour la politique qui voulait me
donner et il avait il s'est révélé
défaillant je crois que ça c'est un choc
culturel français qui de toute façon
sera le cœur de la suite quelques
printemps prochain
[Musique]